do what you can with what you have
where you are
it is hard to fail
but it is worse never to have tried to
succeed
believe you can
and you're halfway there
[Music]
nothing in this world is worth having or
worth doing
unless it means effort
pain
difficulty
i don't pity any man who does hard work
worth doing
i admire him
i pity the creature who does not work
at whichever end of the social scale he
may regard himself as being
whenever you are asked if you can do a
job
tell them
certainly i can
then get busy and find out how to do it
knowing what's right doesn't mean much
unless you do what's right
a man who has never gone to school may
steal a freight car
but if he has a university education
he may steal the whole railroad
with self-discipline
almost anything is possible
the boy who was going to make a great
man must not make up his mind merely to
overcome a thousand obstacles
but to win in spite of a thousand
repulses
and defeats
big jobs usually go to the men who prove
their ability to outgrow small ones
there is only one quality worse than
hardness of heart
and that is softness of head
patriotism means to stand by the country
it does not mean to stand by the
president
courage is not having the strength to go
on
it is going on when you don't have the
strength
in any moment of decision
the best thing you can do is the right
thing
the next best thing
is the wrong thing
and the worst thing you can do
is nothing
honesty first then courage then brains
and all three are indispensable
the only man who never makes mistakes
is the man who never does anything
happiness lies not in the mere
possession of money
it lies in the joy of achievement
in the thrill of creative effort
the joy and moral stimulation of work
must no longer be forgotten in the mad
chase
of evanescent prophets